uh i would like to welcome
everyone to
this much awaited panel discussion
focused on bioinformatics in industry
so uh today uh we have uh we are
privileged to have some of the leaders
from
bioinformatics and biomedical industry
involved in uh pharmaceutical industry
assisting in
modern drug discovery so our first
panelist dr samir khadr is a senior
director of advanced analytical data
science and bioinformatics at
astrazeneca a global science led by
pharmaceutical company so at astrazeneca
he leads the global team of data
scientists biomedical scientists study
statisticians and software engineers he
oversees the profiles and portfolios and
projects in oncology and biopharma to
accelerate drug discovery and
development using biomedical and
clinical data
and machine learning approaches so we
just heard from dr shami sharing
insights
from
pharmaceutical prospective in applying
bioinformatics especially putting
emphasis on data and the technology
applying data science and envisioning
artificial intelligence in the
pharmaceutical industry along with dr
shamir we have mr sarun walia currently
at mit selected as prestigious uh salon
fellow
he
dr mr saroon is a biotechnologist by
training and and with a broad experience
in
areas such as biotechnology consultation
over 14 years and then
worked across three different continents
he is an expert in business strategy r d
planning and pipeline strategies his
work also involved in marketing and
branding strategies in pharma and
biotechnology
our next panelist is mr anthony finbo so
anthony finbo is the ceo ceo of eagle
genomics and has achieved success over
many years as a ceo of technology
businesses he has occupied every seat at
the board
table chairman ceo cfo nxt and
investor director for both public and
private companies and now assists
leaders and their management teams in
meeting and overcoming the most
significant challenges that they might
encounter on their journey
in the panel mr finbo will share his
perspective on different aspects of the
gap that he sees in academia and
industry in bioinformatics and the
vision he has built
to build an ecosystem with students
faculty partners around the world to
advance the bioinformatics or
biotechnology platforms that enables
eagle genomics
as a company
next uh it's an absolute pleasure to
introduce mr nahid fuji uh naheed koji
is the president and ceo of cyclica a
toronto based biotechnology company that
leverages artificial intelligence
computational biophysics to reshape the
drug discovery process so cyclica
provides the pharmaceutical industry
with an integrated holistic and
end-to-end
platform that enhances
how scientists design screen and
personalize medicines for patients and
has recently been named by deep
knowledge analytics as top 20 ai in
pharma companies globally now he is also
co-founder of the alliance of indian
artificial intelligence in healthcare
aaih
of which naheed is one of the four
appointed executive officers so he has
been featured in global mail
forbes
vanity boopsie insider and has been
invited
faculty in a in many universities
describe
discussing topics in such as ai in
medicine
so i welcome you all uh here and before
we go into the actual discussion and uh
begin the session i would like to give
everyone a maybe a brief overview of uh
how the things have shaped up and why we
think this session is so important so uh
from genetics and toxicology to
microbiology to radiology there are
i mean different branches of biology to
specialize in
and out of many bioinformatics is one of
the intruding in is one of the intrusion
fields which enables us to identify uh
evaluate store and retrieve biological
information right something that we have
learned throughout this
omics
symposium now integrating the elements
of uh data
so when it comes to medical uh research
and or product development data science
refers to a broad uh rapidly evolving
field that supports the analytical
process of extracting
knowledge from a variety of data sources
and types right and then integrating
data types and resources such as
this omix data types like genomics
transcriptomics proteomics phenomics
image
images and variables that the data that
we get from there all of this actually
this gives us a holistic understanding
and identifies
in identifying the most meaningful
interferences that leads to the best
decisions so big data in biotechnology
is in today's world is not just only
about genomics but it's also about the
data that may be collected by sensors
variables ingestibles or implantable
sensors that can provide this continuous
data stream for clinical clinical health
clinical trials so in biopharma industry
the focus has now shifted towards
processing data more
effectively and deriving uh relevant
insights to realize its full potential
so by working together different
analytical methods offer this holistic
picture and translate this into
practical steps for product development
maybe marketing or maintenance
strategies so uh with this overview
uh i would let the panelists to take
this forward and
share some insights on how
the future bioinformatics
and data science
that they envision and that they see
with experience and the best approaches
that you may have figured out from your
own experiences
so um i would like to invite first uh
dr shammies to share his thoughts on
this
thank you mohit i really appreciate that
great great background and great
overview and thank you
fellow co-panelists and
in my opinion uh you know we are we're
seeing a uh sort of a transition in in
in our industry especially in
bioinformatics industry and i'm also a
bit uh a little bit concerned about that
too because everybody now calling it you
know data science and then you know
either biological data science or
biomedical data science and we've seen
that also like like you know we have
seen that even even in the evolution of
bioinformatics we have seen that too
like it has gone through certain cycles
but now now we are we are in a in a
stage where
uh you know a bioinformatics person
should have definitely the domain
knowledge domain expertise he should
know his tools databases and all but on
top of that you know having that edge in
ai machine learning and predictive
modeling are going to give them a you
know better access to jobs positions and
in internships in my opinion so that's
that's where where i'm i'm thinking and
then the other
potential uh observation that i have is
that you know
the data science on abroad is you know
is you know there was a hardware
business review piece saying that it's
one of the hardest career in in of the
century but then again so calling it a
biomedical data science is actually good
but but remember you have us you have a
particular edge because you are
trained in this domain from the get go
so that that that would be my thought i
would i would invite um
anthony to kind of comment on his
observation in this in this theme
thanks shamir thanks mohit and also
echoing shamir's comments delighted to
be
participating alongside such a deeply
competent panel here amongst whom i'd
say i'm the interloper
because i didn't and don't have a
background
in bioinformatics um
i'm a serial entrepreneur
i'm an interloper but i can claim some
substance and knowledge because 30 plus
years ago
i did my studies in cybernetics control
engineering and maths
and uh you know that's deeply
information theory related
and i have to say i was delighted to
discover only quite recently that claude
shannon
who's godfather of information science
um
uh i discovered he did his phd in
genomics uh i don't know how many of us
knew that uh but um
it was a delight for me i felt slightly
less of an imposter
but i i come at this from a very
different perspective so look i'm an
entrepreneur i've built uh four or five
companies over the years and uh in a
number of industries
and i've either listed those on the
london stock exchange or the nasdaq or
sold them to us nasdaq listed buyers and
i i entered this industry about five
years ago
and mohit i'm just fascinated to see
how radically understated the size of
the market you projected there on your
initial slides is um i mean i actually
came to this space because of the
tremendous innovation opportunities and
uh you know i'm just following most
recently the guidance provided by
mckinsey and company uh
and by boston consulting group henderson
institute the research establishments
that those consultancy firms have
developed
towards
industry 4.0 which it's increasingly
clear is going to have a very
significant bio dimension to it mckinsey
and company describe it as the bio
revolution
and uh to participate in the
biorevolution boston consulting group
henderson institute describe the
opportunity as nature co-design
and so you know my perspective on the
market is very much bigger than just
drug discovery
it is application of bioinformatics and
data science technologies to enable
customers to participate in the
biorevolution
and to that end we at eagle genomics are
building a company a platform company
to
enable microbiome science networking of
microbiome science in the first instance
because we perceive that to be the most
proximate battleground if you like in
the
bio revolution
now
just particularly to the question
i think uh you know a lot of my frame
has been shaped by what i've done over
the last uh
20 years in telecommunications industry
uh network uh
network uh
software for telecommunications industry
20 plus years ago that industry was
radically disrupted by the introduction
of
tcp ip
and internet protocol before then it was
time division multiplex networks and
the
two-bit code
internet protocol disrupted that
industry first slowly then incredibly
fast what happened in the early stages
of that disruption was that
big companies the big incumbent telco
companies tried to build groups of
people that understood internet protocol
and could build the technologies to
exploit it
and that's what i call first generation
uh you know dynamics in these
enterprises
as the market evolved we started to see
best-in-class applications coming from
external vendors and more of a focus on
the underlying business from the telco
operators and of course our industry
here the industry we're all in some way
participating in has is being disrupted
by the 4-bit code dna
and
first in the early stages we're seeing a
lot of companies experimenting evolving
their capabilities
to exploit that uh understanding of dna
you know
human animal uh microorganisms et cetera
et cetera
but i think what's clear to me as an
outsider is that um
and and
i'm not alone in this uh observation you
know the dirty secret of data science
1.0 is it's not scaling and it's not
scalable
and in order for the industry to really
evolve
data science 2.0 is required
and that's a kind of blend of
informatics and data science skills with
enterprise class technology
and so what i'm trying to do and what
we're trying to do is fuse
enterprise class software skills with
bioinformatics skills data science
skills to create this opportunity to
scale applications that we can promote
to large enterprises that want to
participate in the bio revolution but
also to network research establishments
so that we can enable collaboration
between between the players in this in
this bio revolution and i think that's
liberating tremendous opportunity for
people in the bioinformatics
industry i think the bioinformatics
career path is evolving really really
quickly i think it has to have and it's
incumbent on us to infuse
entrepreneurial skills as well as
technology skills in the in the in the
in the in the students and the you know
researchers that we're cultivating for
this biorevolution and i see nothing but
just incredible opportunity in that
regard
thank you uh dr anthony and thank you
mohit and shamir i can go next uh
i'm darun walia i'm a biotechnologist by
training as mentioned and uh
for the last 15 years i've been working
at the cusp of
biotechnology commercialization as well
as data science
and i agree with a lot of thoughts that
you both have already put forward and i
believe the opportunity is high there
are a few things that i really advise a
lot of people to focus on
is uh
you know going multi-dimensional uh but
what i mean by that is
um for years the data science has been
studied in a very different way from
what biomedical or pharma or discovery
has been studied in
now bioinformatics is a field that of
course ties up the two but uh there are
still so many gaps which are there and
which you know you come to know when
you're speaking to a core
data scientist who's doing machine
learning or building ai models and when
you talk to a research scientist and
he's more willing to do those mouse
models and the research right so how do
you tie up the two
is is there a way where you can
if not an expert is there a way you can
understand both areas really well and
then tie it up with the
commercialization process by
commercialization i mean is uh where
where do we have a window of opportunity
for a drug therapy to be there or a
diagnostic to be there so just having
the commercial acumen tied up with the
data science test and tied up with the
research side is something that i really
want people to focus on in the future
and i will finish off the comments so
naheed kergie it's such a pleasure to be
here today and to listen to and join uh
this panel
um you know
i'm
also not a scientist so anthony there's
two of us and i'll consider myself an
interloper as well and my background is
historically in finance and strategy and
back in the day i spent a lot of time in
humanitarian aid
uh before then coming back and making a
contribution back to the life sciences
which is where i
believe the most impact can be had in
uh in humanitarian work is how do we
make
and make those medicines available
broadly to
people all over the world and how do we
think about data balance data fair data
the availability and the application of
that data in the pursuit of medicine
secure diseases many of which are so
ranked in areas of the world where there
are patients who may not be able to
afford the prices that exist in western
or more european societies but still
have
uh desperate needs and so that's where i
spend a lot of my time and uh it's a
pleasure to be here today you know when
i saw your opening remarks
among it and that one slide where you
just showed the growth of i think it was
data it reminded me vividly of
the growth of the protein data bank
now a little bit about cyclica we are a
quote unquote ai for drug discovery
company and in today's environment we
designed small molecules
to interact with desirable proteins and
avoid undesirable anti-targets or
proteins that you'd want to avoid for
toxicity reasons or for selectivity
reasons
and so for us right now as a 60-plus
person company with offices
uh across the world
our strength on the r d side is in
structural biology computational
structural biology computational
biophysics
and
if you go back to linus pauline and the
determination of the first protein
structure i think that took him
approximately 22 years
to deposit that first protein structure
into the pd what is now the pdb an open
source repository of all protein
structures and then that was back in
1948 it took a lot of time and then in
1978 the pdb became available and if we
look at from 1970 to about 2013 when
cyclica was formed
there was a
fairly exponential
growth in the total number of protein
structures that were available in the
pdp when we started there are about 95
000 protein structures that represented
give or take
twenty to thirty percent of the entire
proteome the twenty twenty thirty
percent of the genome today
hundred and eighty one thousand in a
span of seven years it's doubled
there's more structures being deposited
increasing our knowledge of biology
increase our knowledge and availability
of things to prosecute and when you
couple
that which i will say as an asterisk
that was before alpha fold deep mind
released their alcohol to code and have
now made available essentially the
entire proteome across 20 species and
over the next few years hundreds to
thousands of species before all that
there is this exponential growth of data
so when you take the availability of
proteomics data
genomics data transcriptomics data
clinical trials and real world evidence
data you have a mast
an availability
unlike any other time in history on data
but the most important thing that we've
been thinking about is not the amount of
data but the quality of data
the representation and the fairness of
data and then also how to use that data
in a thoughtful way to solve real
problems not just to take data to solve
any problem
and so for us it's abstracting the
problems that exist in biomedical
science truly understanding
that
you know bifurcating it truly
understanding the problems that exist
and then matching the data with the
algorithms and then with the advance of
cloud computing whether it be gcp amazon
azure and now with nvidia and how
strong they're getting into the
biomedical science space with gpus and
then what's the coming down the pipeline
of quantum and compute uh quantum
computing and so for us it's how do we
take all of this available data
take cloud computing take algorithmic
development whether it be machine
learning or deep learning and start
asking ourselves questions of what's
possible and what are the problems that
can be solved and so for me as a
non-scientist by classical training i've
spent a inordinate amount of my time
studying and spending a lot of time with
people at the interface of those three
areas and at cyclica when we look at the
team of students that we have brought in
some straight out of
bachelor's degrees mscs phds post-docs
people from industry were living within
the intersection of experimental science
computational science and then
humanities do they have the deep empathy
to go and seek out those problems in a
very new way and so i'm happy to kind of
talk a little bit about how we've built
a team we're going from 60 to about 150
over the next couple of years and what
types of skills and experiences we are
looking for and what i encourage
students to go seek
in the pursuit of what is the biggest
opportunity which is the making of
medicines
thank you everyone so really good
insights and i wanted to jump in here
and kind of uh you know direct the
conversation towards uh first of all you
know i will start from something that dr
carter already mentioned as a biology
interested student going into computer
science and then finding himself
at the end in this career of
bioinformatics or data science
and kind of picking up on some of the
other highlights that all of you agreed
on that really industry is not just
solving any problem like in the heat set
but specific problems that are uh you
know the real quote-unquote problems uh
to be solved right so there there
definitely exists kind of like a gap i
think from a student perspective on what
does that look like right and so hearing
about all of these exciting topics
addressing medical needs you know
bringing better medicines to market uh
maybe solving some real scientific
challenges how do you envision somebody
that is still a student or an early
career scientist
kind of understanding what exactly you
know when you envision this big machine
of 150 people working on a particular
problem or you know thousands of people
working on another problem you know how
how can they
kind of
see their future
using bioinformatics some of the
problems that your companies are working
on so maybe i can start with uh anthony
what do you think about that
well it's um you know each and every
company is despite um
you know the opportunity we all have to
research um
uh at our desks uh you know every
company is
by and large a black box and you can
only glean so much about a company from
the outside
and i think uh it's incumbent on us to
therefore provide
structured paths for individuals that
can know only so much that are competent
capable that you know are increasingly
sought after resources is incumbent on
us to create the pathways for them
to
explore and then specialize you know
after a period of time within the
organizations that uh that we're
creating
and i think um
you know i i uh by the way uh you know
another thing i'd say about myself just
quickly is that i i left school and did
an aircraft engineering apprenticeship i
ended up
fulfilling my boyhood dreams really
early as a radio radar engineer on
concord the supersonic airliner um
and and then i got fired because uh
british airways which was the company i
was working with got privatized
but i look back to those four years
where i just learned horizontally across
a huge number of domains before i
started to specialize as
formative in my
career as an entrepreneur
and as someone who's able to do things
and so we're trying to instantiate that
apprenticeship structure apprenticeship
program within eagle genomics we're
working closely with universities in
cambridge
to
develop and deliver
uh
what's described over here in the uk at
least as a level five apprenticeship
so that uh people can explore they can
attach to individuals that are experts
in a range of domains
they can be mentored by these people
they can discover their core skills and
they can recognize where their strengths
lie and therefore where you know they
ought to put their energies because
we're great believers in
strength-based coaching identifying
what people are you know cut out to do
unconsciously without uh you know being
burdened by doing it and then vectoring
them towards that path so they can
really exploit their skills i think
that's one of the one of the things i'd
say the other thing i'd say is that um
you know the field is moving so
incredibly fast that uh you know one has
to look forward as well as backwards you
know the technical when i when i talk
about backwards i mean the technologists
that are available today to learn you
know they are going to be evolving so
quickly
that um you know one shouldn't be
worried too much about specializing and
one should be open-minded about um
you know how to evolve in the future
what i'd say also about you know the
focus we have is that we're
you know in in much the same way as
nahid has described his business we are
trying to
network microbiome science so we're
using uh network science as the kind of
fundamental fundament on which to build
our platform and our business um
delighted to say we we
we we
raised series a funding last year and we
managed to get one of the leading
thinkers on network science laszlo
barabashi to invest in our business
we're about to raise a series b
round of funding
um but i think um
what i'm trying to describe is a picture
that's highly fluid in the early stages
so that we can attract the right
resources provide them with a framework
such that they can
learn broadly and then specialize deeply
and i think we we have to offer that
kind of career
a path to individuals lest we try to get
people you know too focused too quickly
great thank you so uh dr carter would
you like to add to that from your
perspective
sure thank you yeah uh in you know some
interesting statistics i want to share
with this group actually
over the last year i might have
interviewed more than 100 uh
you know quote-unquote data scientists
you know sort of junior to senior level
role
and then also been leading some of our
internship in a program global
internship program and we recruited
um more than 15 interns over the last
six months but we received more than
800 applications
right like you just you know just think
about it like you know and then for each
and every one of you who are students
and trainees in this group how can you
differentiate
and this is just you know one company's
one department you know looking to fill
a few internship decisions and that
particular position uh the one where we
got 800 was actually
for a u.s based unfortunately this was
only open for u.s based graduate
students you know there are like certain
country requirements for some of these
positions
but we received applicants applications
from everywhere in the world which is
okay now unfortunately we can hire all
of them
and then the you know and then when i
was going through that whole process you
know with the pre-screening screening
and then you know finally interviewing a
sick you know uh
a lot of candidates we had you know we
finally hired our interns actually
they're about to finish their projects
and all
what i wanted to kind of tell you is
that what what what was that quality
that you know led to that final offer
you know from from my perspective right
like they were you know it doesn't
matter you know the you know in an
interview and that's the traditional
interview process where you send an
application you you know you review the
cv you know you bring them in and then
you have a face-to-face interview but
then that first step is to to select
your cv so it's definitely important
what you put in your cv so if you're a
student
make sure that you have some kind of a
project-based learning be you know
whether it's you know putting extra time
with your professor or collaborating
with another friend or working at a
company that's you know straight across
your university
go ahead and do that that's as important
as your coursework i know schedule is
stuff and you know right now we live in
a pandemic world we cannot really go in
in in irl that's not possible but then
you can reach out to them send an email
make sure that you have that trust so
one of the factor that stood out for
these applicants but they had some kind
of experience and then then then the
question would come from students oh
that means we we always have to have a
project to get to an internship no
that's not the case you you can still be
doing you know a undergrad in
anthropology and want to do human data
science that differentiate you just like
what naheed was mentioning right like
you you bring in a different perspective
to the group that's also okay
and then the other part is when you come
into the interview it's your
communication and clarity it doesn't
matter whether you worked on i don't
know the the predicting seed properties
or you know you you worked in
identifying how to launch satellites it
doesn't matter unless and until you are
able to give your elevator pitch in like
in three minutes or so we all have you
know
if you take humanity itself our our
attention span is reducing right like
you know we all have that issue uh if
you if you think about the most leading
social media platform right now is stick
talk and average time a length of a tick
tock which is 15 seconds
so we are living in that world so you
have to have that you know 50 you know
your elevator pitch ready you have to
have clarity and communication and then
you know and then let's say if you hire
you what matters the most it's not maybe
it doesn't matter whether you are the
worst one of the world's best machine
learning scientists or programmers these
these skills that we talked about you
have you can communicate clearly you can
you can have good engagement with your
stakeholders in an industry perspective
whether it's your group that you work
with you either your line manager or the
team that you're working with and then
also making sure that you understand
the change management aspects that you
will bring into the table what i meant
by that is which is you know whether
it's you know stakeholder engagement and
change management this might be new to
many students here because traditionally
we don't teach
management or strategy to our
science stem based i mean ste based uh
programs of course m
if it's mathematics or management
depends on that
but stakeholder engagement is how do you
how do you deliver your project in a
refined and in sort of a very much uh a
plea in a predefined way and make sure
that all the deliverables are met within
your within your schedule and then you
need to have some kind of a direct
communication line with your all your
stakeholders of the project who either
funded your position or funded that
project and then what's change
management let's say you're building
this beautiful algorithm whether it's
for you know small molecule prediction
or or to identify a cancer patient
subtype who's going to use that
algorithm will they use their algorithm
are they going to trust in that
algorithm what baseline did you use did
you communicate that of course with the
stakeholders but also
with your users if you don't have a user
a million multi-million dollar
investment in ai is not going to have
any benefit
so these are the things you have to
think about right like of course your
science and technology skills your
scientific and technology skills are
important i'm not saying that they are
not important
but are you able to communicate your
idea clearly are you ready to engage
with your stakeholders are you ready to
have this dialogue to do change
management
these are important skills and this kind
of carry forward you know it doesn't
matter whether you're an intern you're
coming as for a full-time role or you in
your leadership journey throughout this
this this segment of this particular
industry this matters a lot so
the long story short version of that is
you know to make sure your your
communication and clarity that's going
to be the number one skill it's not your
python programming or you know how to
run single cell sequencing i mean like
they're good they're great
but
are you able to interpret and explain
your result to your lab to your group
your collaborators that matters a lot
right do you mind if i jump in and just
provide
a perspective from a small budding
company not an az company and i agree a
lot with what shamir said in in
overall remarks but there's a couple
nuances as
students are thinking about applying to
a earlier stage company
than a large pharma and i will say aaz
and cyclic have done a lot of work with
astrazeneca and paul agapow is a close
friend and shamir i'm sure in the data
science group you've worked with paul
and you know we've done some and
published some work with aaz in the data
science space but here's what i'd like
to say to students who are thinking
about applying to earlier stage
companies
generally when you're applying to an
earlier stage company a seed stage
typically five to seven eight people
series a eight to twenty thirty forty
people and then beyond depending
especially in the biotech stage that's
usually where they line up
if you're applying earlier on
i would highly encourage
you to truly know
the entrepreneur or the co-founders of
the company listen to and read what
they've been saying in the marketplace
and understand what that company is
talking about and match your views and
visions to that and what can you do to
augment
because there is going to be whether
you're a co-op
an intern or co-op an employee and a
contributor going into a management role
that becomes a very important role for
that company and of a group of dozens to
hundreds of applicants
they're going to invest a lot of time
reading through each one at cyclica at
each stage we've done hr with students
well at some points in time we've done
it poorly at some points in time but
what we've continued to invest in is the
um is the student marketplace
we have rolling co-ops with the
university of waterloo university of
toronto we brought in co-ops from
northeastern university where we have
the office in boston that's something
that we pride ourselves heavily in
and then we've continued to disseminate
content through what was previously
called aia my homework an online forum
where we talk about everything from
target selection to clinical development
and how ai is playing to roam we'll have
our team and then external folks come
and talk about that generally made
available to high school and university
and graduate students
and so this becomes really important but
what i'd encourage as you learn there's
all this material that startup companies
disseminate to that market to build
their brand
don't make it an application that is
cookie cutter
because that company is differentiate
they're they're fighting every single
day to differentiate themselves so it
behooves you as an applicant to say how
you're differentiating yourself and how
you and that company are going to help
differentiate
and so a i've seen far too many just
you know application that you can take
out the name of cyclic and replace it
with any other company
and that loses traction in our eyes
because
we are going to in the information age
of 15 second tick tock videos
we fight against that fallacy and we
instead encourage all of our hiring
managers to read everything
and as we go through reading that
information it come becomes abundantly
clear those who are just applying
because there's a job application versus
those who are genuinely interested
in earnestly joining cyclica and the
last thing i would say is that there's
two types of applicants there are those
who
are deeply immersed in the subject
matter of bioinformatics or
computational chemistry or computational
biophysics whether they be
uh you know third year undergrad
students or graduate students or
post-docs those are the ones that had a
directionality to their educational
experience and they have clarity
generally as to where they want to fit
and then there are those who are
anthropologists who want to bring a
human element to shamir's point
highly valuable but maybe they went down
a different career path educationally
but now they want to make the leap i
have an undergraduate degree in
psychology and organizational behavior i
spend time in finance and strategy and
somehow i joined
and co-founded an ai and drug discovery
company and now i'm the ceo of this
company
so there is merit in the non-classical
approach
we have hired musicians
as data scientists who then self-code
learn to self-code we brought on
musicians to help on our design of our
user interface for our internal and so
it really becomes how do you tell your
story depending on your directionality
of your career related or unrelated
if you are genuinely interested in
joining that company your brand is the
sum of all experiences that a person
will have with you so you've got to make
sure that as quickly as possible but as
consistently as possible you're able to
tell that story as to why that company
should choose you
uh
would you like to add anything to that
sure i think uh my panelists uh had a
really strong point so i'll just keep it
very short but i i think shami put up a
fantastic point when he said you need to
differentiate your application or you
need to differentiate yourself and
there are various ways i have seen uh
applicants differentiate i mean
some of them really use social media
really well and by social media i mean
linkedin like you know putting your
yourself out there and and sharing the
work you've done
it can be small research but uh
positioning it how it can have an impact
in the long term or how it can add value
to the company that you are applying for
um another thing that really works well
is
understanding the company that you're
applying for not all companies are the
same you may want to keep different
resumes uh some are focusing on say
oncology you want to focus what you've
done in that area some are focusing on
say cardiovascular you cannot have the
same kind of research for both
it's again points to differentiate
yourself because if i'm reading
something where i'm working for an
oncology company and someone has that
experience yes he'll be weighed slightly
higher
and
of course it doesn't mean that uh you
know you have to know everything uh what
it means is how you can position
yourself for that role that yes you are
the person for this job
and then uh the other point that both
naheed and
put forward is on the teamwork side of
it i think i would love to have a team
player on my team um so someone who can
work well with others and there are ways
you can distinguish or you there are
ways you can
focus on in the in the interviews and in
the overall process
and and someone who can show that impact
even if he's not done a lot of research
but is willing to learn and willing to
make an impact so i think these are
certain ways where you can really
differentiate yourself and that's the
key point i would take away from the
conversation
thank you i think it was it was amazing
that we all discussed all of this
because if i have to summarize there was
so much value in all of the
conversations that we have had it's
really difficult to summarize all of it
but i do have a few points that i would
want to highlight here so all of you
being
leaders
and
being able to do a lot of training in
this
manner where we are talking about
integrating other players into our team
and then it requires uh to have that
sort of understanding where i mean this
process is like get simpler like it
should not be more complex uh then and
then it becomes challenging so what i've
heard from
shamir is that like
there are some skills and
that that that is required but there are
some other soft skills also which are
required so
at times i think it helps to think them
through and
have a strategy or like a think about
the things that could happen and that
one kind of you know vision can comes
from this sort of understanding where
you are telling that these are important
things that we have to consider so that
i think that is that gives us a lot of
value to the students who are listening
here and maybe thinking that okay maybe
this is a x scenario and if i have to
put myself in that scenario what are the
different outcomes uh different people
different thinking
that i could address while being in a
group a well-being and being a team
player so i think it requires a lot of
thinking in that context and
uh being able to understand uh about the
company i saw that
like one thing that i would wanted to
mention especially for a big pharma or
like when we would want to
understand that what is actually going
on there so the difference like what we
see in research labs many times we kind
of look for the pi and then we find the
articles and then we find that the
methods that they've been using it's
really kind of
easy for a student to
investigate further about a research lab
and
look for the pi and go for like an
internship or something like that but
when it comes to uncomfort to a company
um the the openness uh there is is
limited
uh so i mean
for us to understand that how
bioinformatics differs in a company
versus a research is a gap or is also a
challenge
so dr shami what do you think about this
yeah sure uh so you know there is
nothing like a perfect candidate right
like we always have there is a human
element to hiring for that matter and we
don't expect you know everybody to know
everything and within our data science
and ai group
we have a significant
section of our group is actually
dedicated to learning and development
so you will bring certain skills to the
table but additional skills whether
let's say you have some background in
statistical modeling but you want to
learn computer vision we will have
courses or we will immerse you within
the team that actually doing computer
vision day in day out so we we need to
make sure that you come in and then you
can build your uh you know
you know your technology portfolio your
skills like that so that's always
possible in in a you know in a formal
company like you know in a company like
ours or other players in the industry as
well
and then um the the other part is like
you know what we have to understand here
is
you know
if you take bioinformatics as a whole
like what some of these parts of
bioinformatics will we will do
internally some of these would be done
by cro some of this would be done by
other types of companies you know that
like you know uh smaller companies that
are actually hyper focused on that
particular type of analytics and then
what you will do internally might be
still at the bleeding edge so you have
to get ready for that it's going to be a
little bit different
than a traditional academic setting
where you will keep on analyzing or
develop improving your pipeline we
because we need to move move the needle
we need to push the boundaries because
anything that you do right now is
actually like you know if you're in a
more r d focused role it will be you're
potentially contributing towards a drug
that would eventually get developed
five to ten years down the line
so you have you're working backwards
right like you're not going to get an fp
approval you know in this year or this
month for you know for for an rna stage
molecule right now so you you will
basically contribute that to working
towards what could happen in five to ten
years and if each and every one of us
think about where bioinformatics was
five to ten years ago versus now you
know we can literally see it growing
right like you know whether it's access
to high performance computing or more
algorithms more methods we see that so
so we just the future readies just be
ready to sing in and and uh if you know
that's what i would say and go with an
open mind what that was uh tyron's point
right like you know if you're good at
good at certain skills whether it's you
know whether it's writing communications
you know social media or or even as
simple as making videos
have a catalog of your work somewhere so
that we can see that we can we can
understand your your your skills okay
you bring insert something that's that's
unique and then you want to come in and
and become a data scientist or or or
running pipelines like this this this
this can be done that's for sure and one
more last point i could i could make
here is that
the industry is seeing
an influx of career in this space right
like you know and he also mentioned
about this
we we have uh you know uh initially it
was just data scientists now it's data
engineer data
data engineer data is there's two
separate roles now we have you know we
used to have you know devops to support
the whole development team now we have
mlabs ai ops now you know down the line
for you know five years and i don't know
maybe there's a bioinformatics or i
don't know i'm like so there are new
things that would eventually evolve
and you can shape up your career towards
that so be open and one advice that i
could give to the students is that just
because
you know you have strong biology you
doesn't code don't think you cannot work
in in bioinformatics because we need a
lot of analysts
we need a lot of people to do
biocuration we need a lot of people to
validate the algorithm we need a lot of
test engineers so there is nothing like
okay a goodbye informatics job means you
know database programming and advanced
machine learning no it's a you know it's
fundamentally it's communication writing
skills you're you know like i said you
know stakeholder engagement you know
these are these are the skills and on
top of that be good at one thing whether
it's programming whether it's genetics
either it's
curating variants it doesn't matter
there is always always an opportunity
and and i personally don't believe
even with influx of all of this advanced
machine learning or applied machine
learning i'm someone who's doing this
for i started doing it in 2002 maybe
2001 it's going to be 20 years i've seen
that applied ai in biomedicine for the
last roughly 20 years
you know don't worry algorithms are not
going to take your job don't worry about
that you you know don't worry about it
it's good to have that good algorithm
development skill but we still need
curators we still need uh developers and
engineers and all so yeah so that would
be my take on it those are some
fantastic points uh jamir i would love
to like uh add a bit here
and uh you know one of the things i also
see when people transition from research
to the
corporate side is the i think the people
succeed when they are able to relate to
what makes the company succeed
for instance
when you are in doing your research your
focus is on okay let me focus on this
particular aspect of the value chain and
you forget the downstream value chain
and the downstream is your clinical
development your commercialization and
bringing the product to market
where you can help patients right so the
more you converse with your counterparts
downstream like talking to clinicians oh
how how do you decide the end points uh
what patient segments are we targeting
how is this research adding value
downstream and then also talking to the
say the commercialization folks like
what is the patient need uh
and and then you know just having that
dialogue with your colleagues across the
value chain that really helps when
you're entering a company from the
research side so yeah
and if i may just to
pick up an amplify on what tyron has
just said there and i'm
my experience is often that with people
transitioning from
science to industry that they are very
focused on
the um
you know the the ground truth and the
proximate deviation from a ground truth
um
and uh sometimes and most often in an
entrepreneurial environment certainly
building a company there's a lot of
ambiguity
and huge amount of abstraction is
required to be successful and you know
perhaps this is most simply
characterized with fixed versus growth
mindset i think what tyron's saying you
know the people that are successful in
reaching out to understand downstream uh
the shape of what's coming those are
people that are required to have this
growth mindset i think you know to
really benefit in the future that is a a
key attribute i'd say
i don't have too much more to add and i
want to make sure that if there are any
other questions we can go to that but
the only thing that i would
close out with is
know what you don't know as well and go
seek out that knowledge
education is the best competitive
differentiator
and it doesn't have to come through
classical means coursera edx
there are so many different you know mit
with the sloan management they have and
the relationship with coursera i have no
affiliation with mit i've just taken a
bunch of courses and i have four more
lined up for the rest of the year
you know
within the company or outside of the
company just continue
to see trends that you like
follow some and then create your own and
the only way that's that
that's possible is through a continuous
education
and b application and testing those
things out in the context of what works
what doesn't work and continue to
iterate you know you can't call yourself
a ml scientist a data scientist if
you're not willing or able to daisy and
update your own mental model based on
things that are happening in the
industry
and so students just continue to
whether you're high school student
or you're 65 years old and looking to
get into a new industry or myself which
continuing to try and learn and stay
ahead of stuff
just continue to educate
so thank you everyone this really kind
of like what i heard some of the things
and i heard very different things you
know so anthony mentioned they have an
established apprenticeship program with
a particular university and i'm
imagining you're kind of trying to build
that out further
and then uh you know shamir mentioned
that he has
uh interviewed a lot of
applicants from around the world there
are specific positions and specific
skills that they're looking for but
there's a lot of this corporate
structure on top of basic skills
and then i heard also from
and indeed you know as a smaller company
how important it is to kind of realize
the vision and kind of align yourself
with that vision and kind of highlight
how you can contribute to that and grow
and continue and expand and then uh
tarun also mentioned how uh you know
understanding the domain and kind of
like showcasing what you have done in
that domain is very important so that
brings me to this question of
relationship with universities uh you
know you you can obviously build your
own ecosystem right you can participate
in research and showcase what your
company is putting in that space
but in many cases you know students
don't come from nowhere right they're
already a part of an ecosystem they're
already a part of something that
they've been led to believe or to kind
of envision themselves right and those
examples that they have in front of them
and the pathway that they've went
through that kind of shows them what
they might be possible you know might be
able to achieve so my question is really
um you know how can universities prepare
students for careers that you see in
industry
specifically for companies that hire
bioinformaticians or from those
backgrounds uh you know how can faculty
at universities how can the
administration at the universities
potentially work with companies like
yours
to establish that pathway and kind of
provide that future for their students
i can take that one first if you'd like
i don't come from a research institution
so for profit but we have
at the moment
relationships with over 220 research
institutions globally as part of our
cyclica academic partnership program
and we open up in its acronym cap to
work with academic and research
institutions for two reasons number one
we make available our computational drug
discovery platform available to
uh pis principal investigators within
those research institutions at no cost
to them
in the pursuit of advancement of basic
science and the translation into
potentially commercial viable
assets that could maybe one day become
drugs and the second and most important
reason is to build brand recognition
with the next wave of
uh students and researchers who will be
trained under those pis and they become
available into the marketplace
eventually whether they be at if big
pharma companies like az
genomics companies
like with anthony or they continue to
remain within academia and
postdocs and then become a pi themselves
how do we help train or affect
behavioral change in the minds of
many scientists on what is possible with
computational approaches both
bioinformatics physics based ai machine
learning deep learning
so we think a lot about that and we've
instituted that cap program and it's
been highly highly successful
then there's another type of
relationship and i'll point to a few
examples i think boston
does this exceptionally well
and so i'm sure tarun will talk about
how
and i'm not picking on boston again i
have no affinity i'm canadian but like
boston has done this exceptionally well
stanford who's done this exceptionally
well i think stanford i saw a release
recently in the past 24 hours where it
stated that over the past decade they
started 680 companies and the total
market cap of those companies is close
to 20 billion or 50 billion dollars or
something like that just from startup
companies that have happened come out of
stanford and so what does that then mean
that generally means is that those
companies are created
with
brains that have been educated in those
research institutions that then go
translate go raise venture funding or
funding from other environment strategic
partners
go translate that research
hire people create
actual economy and jobs generally from
the ecosystem as the term was used and
probably likely from their academic
institution that they came from and so
there becomes this virtual cycle of
training educating and then deploying
into the marketplace and there are a
couple areas in the world that have done
this really really well i i think canada
and specifically the beltway between the
university of waterloo and like mcgill
university in montreal have done this
very well especially at the intersection
of experimental sciences like biomedical
scientists sciences as well as
computational and computer science ai
etc
with university of waterloo being a very
very strong school at that frontier
and right at the epicenter is the vector
institute in toronto and then mila the
montreal machine learning institute in
montreal and what they've done is
brought in the hospital networks the
research institutions with industry and
government funding to not only train the
next wave of students but to provide
them with the basic uh pillars to enable
the commercialization or translation of
that research into partially viable
entities and so you're looking now at
where is the next frontier of innovation
yes absolutely boston with mit and
harvard and northeastern which is really
coming up
and then you have in california but you
have a lot of
small little sectors that are growing
globally and i'd point to what's
happening in toronto and in canada
in our space as probably the vectors of
influence pointing there
yes thanks
um just echoing
uh the model that now he described you
know what we're trying to do in
networking microbiome science is
connecting the leading research
establishments that are driving the art
and the science
with the enterprises that are seeking to
exploit that
we focused uh not so much on drug
discovery in the short term although
that's increasingly part of our
focus but helping
industry participants in nutrition and
food and nutrition
cosmetics and personal care and ag bio
to
network understanding of microbiome
science into their models
and on our platform connecting the
research establishments with the
enterprises so they can collaborate with
us if you like as the glue in the middle
around some particular projects we're
also
often sponsoring phd students within the
end within the research establishments
we describe them as knowledge partners
that we're working with and we have we
already have quite a highly distributed
business we are
in cambridge in the uk in the centre of
london kings cross what's called the
knowledge quarter next to the alan
turing institute the francis crick
institute google deep mind
we're in manhattan in the new york
genome center in potsdam on the potsdam
science park
in paris in microsoft's ai factory and
also in hyderabad where we have 30
people already so we're trying to create
local partnerships with research
establishments because we want to foster
relationships and
you know encourage candidates from those
research establishments to come through
to join us but it's really important to
us that we are
uh creating clusters where humans can
interact with humans not if in this you
know quasi-virtual world in which we
which we still inhabit um
it's not necessary to be uh together
with uh you know a mentor or whatever
every single day but it's absolutely
germane to our
evolution and building of our business
that we afford people the opportunities
to interact with other humans on a
frequent and regular basis so that's
driving our model
um and maybe i could ask actually to
roon to answer next and and together
with that if you could kind of address
this question uh how do organizations
deal with converging business
uh and scientific rigor so business uh
kind of you know interests and
scientific rigor together without
damaging either
wow that's a tough one
um so you know that's that's uh
there are a lot of uh
conversations around that you know how
can
we have best of the both worlds and uh
make sure
that the research we are doing that's
one hand and the commercialization that
we're doing that's the other hand and
how can we succeed by joining both hands
right
and uh often the often the trick here is
communication
i mean an open communication where
you know you you you're empathizing with
the other party that yes i understand
what you're doing uh not blaming the
other party if there is failure failures
are bound to come the failure can be
from the research side it can be from
the
business side and uh then i think that's
where uh the role of the ceo and i think
anthony and naheed can vouch in there as
well
how can ceo play that role where he he
uh showcases that yes the business side
is important as well as the research
side and and collectively is when we win
so so making sure that the whatever
activity we are doing by activity i mean
it can be experimental research it can
be understanding uh
what is happening from a clinical
perspective and also understanding what
is happening from the business
perspective and and and mentioning how
all of these tie up together
and uh
and
and i've seen that you know sometimes
the business perspective is that hey i
know what i'm doing i don't need to
understand you are a researcher you
don't understand this business so so
just just aligning both parties there
and it's a good question uh because uh
often it can be detrimental for the
organization so so what what worked for
me when i was working in this area was
having sit togethers with both parties
together and somehow being that bridge
that can help communicate because you
need to understand both sides of the
business to be a good mediator here and
and i think i would love to hear even
naheed anthony's perspective here
because as ceos they are doing it uh day
in and day out
tyrone if i may just go directly to that
uh you you've just pinpointed the
primary job of the ceo both internally
and externally is to be translator
and modulator of information delivered
from different sources speaking perhaps
you know all english but fundamentally
different languages towards a common
goal and i think at this early stage in
the evolution of our industry where we
are bringing together uh individuals
from backgrounds uh educational
backgrounds and um you know experiential
backgrounds
to a particular focused endeavor from a
range of different uh environments
translation is is the core skill and
that's the other reason by the way why
we're so focused on this uh
apprenticeship approach because we're
trying to create the mechanisms to
enable people to understand
the voices from the range of sources
earlier in their careers because they
get too siloed particularly perhaps you
know most often with phd uh postdocs you
know very focused uh and and uh without
the sort of constant perturbation uh if
you like uh that that forces the
individual to explore
the broader environment beyond the core
focus um that becomes increasingly
difficult later in the career
yeah
not much again
you're getting
front line seats to some very thoughtful
perspective
there's not much more i can add to that
but i don't also want to remain mute on
this important topic
i would say unlike
any other time in history today there's
a convergence of skill sets based on a
bunch of stuff that now exists that did
not exist even 10 years ago again i go
back to the availability
of high quality
a lot of high quantum and relevant data
um that is
when
trained with new algorithms like ai or
nl deep learning what have you and
powered by
new infrastructure cloud computing or
even that which is coming down the
pipeline you now have this convergence
of opportunity
and so unlike before where chemists used
to talk to chemists
biologists used to talk to biologists
clinical scientists used to talk to
clinical scientists you're now seeing
pharma
generally over the past number of years
create an environment where these people
are sitting together sharing ideas
and therefore incubating
uh converged approaches so med chemists
aren't only talking to med chemists
i think novartis has come out and
actually led the charge in terms of at
least how they branded themselves
whether practically i have no idea but
they brought chemists and biologists and
computational folks sitting together
and so as i think about that model and
vis-a-vis cyclica
we have internship programs where we
bring on biomedical scientists
bioengineers computational chemists but
then expose them to different areas
within the organization so we have a
group of applied scientists which is
what we call them there are drug
discovery hunters med chemists organic
chemist biochemist biologists folks that
have lived at the bench to do a bunch of
stuff
but who have a propensity towards
computational techniques or data science
techniques
now whether or not they trained that way
as part of their
education formal education where they
did it on the side
what we've brought in is a group of
people who are really curious about not
doing it the classical way
and so i would continue to encourage you
know the company that you want to join
are they able to offer you that whether
it be through formal training or
apprenticeship programs like anthony's
company
we do very similar tag teams bring the
teams together and make sure it is
interwoven and not separate
but then i would continue to encourage
the group of students here
no matter where you are in your career
to continue to seek out that level of
information
bolted onto the thing that you spike in
the most what you do and what you're
most passionate about but continue to
add on to it and from a company
standpoint make sure that they're able
to fulfill that curiosity that they're
able to scratch their curiosity itch for
you
as a result you're able to contribute
back to that company bring a new
perspective but then also leave much
more i'd say broadly and like
you'll be able to fight the uh the curse
of kind of peripheral vision or
obfuscating peripheral vision
thank you thank you nade i think uh all
of these thoughts are i mean very
helpful so i mean that brings us to the
next question which is on behalf of the
community
so
we
get to interact with a lot of
faculty in from different universities
and
they would want to maybe get involved in
a research which is more directed
towards the industry so the question
that we get is that how can we get it
level to an industrial grade research
and we do understand that there's like
there's a gap but uh
when we think about a community so i
think there is a possibility to leverage
that community so uh maybe shamir i can
ask you in that aspect of how do you
think astrazeneca as a company has
looked into to address this to utilize
maybe a community or
you know under make them
bridge this gap
sure yeah and then you know i can i can
also add
a quick point for the previous question
that you know the time couplings were
discussing so we are always looking for
talent we always have uh internship
co-op other types of decisions you can
always look into our
data science and ai career page and
apply directly and then also you can uh
you know
reach out to potential tv members you
know including myself through linkedin
or twitter or whatever is your preferred
social media and you know we're always
looking for uh collaborations as well
and
coming back to the collaboration
specifically so we do have
both you know structured and you know
sort of at hope uh collaborative uh
engagement throughout uh you know uh
with with our community
uh in the research community here and
that means like for example we do
collaborate with cambridge mathematics
program so we we do research
collaboration we have we have co
sort of a co-founder of the cambridge
center for ai in medicine in the uk we
have collaborations with uh
several other leading uh you know
research
groups that we collaborate with and this
those are like sort of structured so
that's one fun approach that we're
taking and then also we have you know we
we strongly know that um we don't we
won't be able to solve all of the
problems that we have right like so we
do have what you call as a a platform
called cost solved like we need
communities in order to solve some of
our grand challenging uh problems
actually and if you can uh
you know look for astrazeneca causal
platform it's led by a friend uh who
leads the emerging innovation unit and
you can see a number of projects or
problems that are that we want we are
actually openly looking for
collaborators so that's a second
approach and the third one is you know
like like for example my group primarily
looking doing machine learning research
and we are always looking for
collaborators we know the problem is
these are some of the grand challenges
in the industry we need to work together
as we're always looking for
collaborators so that's on an individual
project level or an individual research
engagement level we can definitely think
about so it's the structured programs
that is cost solve and then also uh
between uh potentially interested
research groups can collaborate as well
so that's great to know anthony do you
have something for the i mean
researchers like faculty or early
researchers to collaborate on because
many times what we have heard from them
is that they they wanted to work on
exciting projects they have students but
the research idea is something that does
not align well or is not maybe properly
structured at times so maybe at an
industry level if that sort of help or
at least guidance is there that could
actually lead to some great outcomes
with whatever resources that they have
well thanks mohit i think you know it's
challenging to to give you a coherent
answer
in describing sort of point solutions um
i think
we're trying to look at this at the
macroscopic
level by trying to understand the
incentives of particular research
establishments
what drives their interest and
focus in engaging
with a particular enterprise or what
their
research niche focus is and whether we
can match that with a particular
enterprise that's looking
at you know the gap in its own
capability to be filled with that uh
understanding and we're actually trying
to instantiate on our platform
mechanisms for matching to enable that
so that we understand the incentives of
the research establishments we
understand the incentives of the
enterprises and we can seek to match
um
you know uh that's a challenging
endeavor but it's already bearing fruit
because we're selling our software
application the e-data scientists into
large enterprises and they're asking us
to network data from research
establishments on the other side so the
beginning of this
ecosystem orchestration opportunity you
know we're seeing that now but i think
we're we're still com some significant
way
from being able to you know
say to a particular researcher within a
particular uh you know knowledge partner
or research establishment you know look
you're doing interesting work this
enterprise is interested in perhaps
collaborating with you i do see i do see
over the course of the next five to ten
years
the evolution of uh you know more clever
data orientated marketplace structures
where we do match uh research
establishments with enterprises because
that's that's that's necessary for the
acceleration of the science that we're
all involved in at the moment
thank you
so one question that i have especially
maybe if nahi we can answer that so we
heard about uh top institutions being
one of those places where the companies
look forward for innovation as well as
for students
so there are also
we got to
work with a lot of
students from africa especially we have
a collaboration in nigeria and there are
other countries where students are there
who are equally capable
but they are not exposed to these
opportunities but the things have like
kind of changed with the covet uh
forward the silver lining that many
things are now online
and they get an opportunity so
do you have anything for
students like that who are coming from
maybe like so-called third world
countries where the education system is
not as structured or as good as other
countries comparatively
good science happens all over the world
you don't have to have a mit or an
oxford or a cambridge or university of
toronto or berkeley logo next to your
resume
now
so that is a firm belief
secondly you know from our perspective
you will quickly suss out from the
company that you're applying to whether
or not they have that ethical alignment
look at the people on their website
um are they generally
building a company that is of
like-minded people to them or have
similar degrees from similar types of
institutions
or is it a little bit more diverse and
are they open to
you know that beliefs i i think
unfortunately i think a large percentage
of companies generally especially in
north america and many in europe will go
and hire from institutions that they
were trained at or that they know very
closely we've tried to push on that
belief
there are complexities in bringing on as
a canadian or a us or european company
bringing on co-ops or employees in other
countries
so there is a hurdle that companies need
to overcome
to justify bringing on a student whether
it be in nigeria or in rwanda or in the
philippines or in papua new guinea and
that's tax and you know employment law
and all these things and so how do you
convince the company that you are the
best person for this and for them to
make that investment
um so that's you know from the
role of a individual applying to the
company
now there's the role of the company and
what they need to do and i continue to
encourage companies especially early
stage that if it's not us
that is going you know especially the
leaders in the industry if we're not
willing to think differently then it's
never going to happen so i spend a lot
of my time
globally outside of north america and
western societies and i've spent a lot
of time in
in asia in many of the emerging markets
i spent a lot of time in africa you know
my family is east africa in kenya and
tanzania and i was at the next einstein
forum in kigali rwanda in 2018 and i got
to speak to
on behalf of the chancellor of the
university of rwanda
a professor at carnegie mellon and the
managing director of elsevier we got on
stage to speak with 2 000 stem students
at the university of rwanda to encourage
them to continue to pursue
um in their passions to help them think
about
how to brand themselves to companies
that they may want to join that aren't
doing business in their country but then
also how do my rallying cry was how do
we as a
as companies that have their resources
available how do we continue to invest
in those students whether it be through
technology access
education
or through internships or other
environments to bring them over so i i'd
say
we're not nearly perfect
but it's worth the fight you know we
have as our director of
drug design platform team he was
educated in south africa right like
we have students that we've brought we
have students from india that we have
brought over to canada students from
china that we've brought in over from
china to study and to work at cyclica
now that mindset has to shift from a lot
of companies to enable more open
environments
but from a student perspective that's
not your business your businesses
continue to fight and differentiate
and if you want it just go tell a really
good story as to why that company should
choose you over somebody that's in their
own backyard
thank you i think that is a lot of
courage to all of the students here
now uh
maybe elia do you have something to add
yeah someone has to say something there
was a hand
raised
by their own doesn't they you wanted to
add something to this and especially for
the students in india no no uh i was
just clapping him and i didn't want to
raise his hand we i agreed with the
point that uh naheed said uh i wouldn't
take much time but yes i think i'm in
complete agreement uh with naheed here
on both the points um
the world is your oyster i think uh the
the i it does not matter these days if
you are bringing value it does not
matter where you're coming from
and the focus has to be on showcasing
how can you
you know
make that impact create that value for
the organization that you want to join
in so focus on that rather than
so you know again there are
controllables in life and then there are
uncontrollables
so wherever you've already studied it's
an uncontrollable now so let's not focus
there right so i only want to focus on
what i can control what i can control is
the next steps and that is maximizing
the value that i can bring on the table
just focus on that don't even think
where you're coming from and then second
is again in agreement with naheed
it also matters what the philosophy of
the company is
um if the company is someone they only
want to recruit from certain places
don't apply there i mean that's their
loss not your loss
so so so figure it out and and and go
for that opportunity that you think
you're capable of don't let the past or
don't let where you're from uh let you
discourage uh that's one thing i
definitely want to put on the table
so i i just want to jump in here and i
want to mention that uh you know it's
been really a pleasure to hear all of
your perspectives on these important
topics from all of our
participants we want to ask you for just
your final remarks and we want to then
move on to uh the poster competition uh
but i do want to just uh you know ask
everyone if you want to add you know a
minute or two of final remarks before we
move on thank you
i'll kick it off as i just want to add
one more comment to this important topic
that taren and i just covered
i'll give a quick example and then i'll
conclude
um
now more than ever especially in a
ongoing post whatever you want to call
it covet environment what's become clear
to companies is that talent is global
and you're seeing not only talent but
venture capital institutions are funding
they used to fund in their own backyard
because why not and now they're saying
well let's go fund globally and where
capital goes and teams grow and things
are leveling off to an extent for
companies are looking to hide and so now
more than ever ramp up your effort to go
find those institutions that it you're
that admire for that that you are most
aligned with that you admire that you
are
scientifically passionate about
um i'll give a great example of a
student who approached cyclica
she's now on our machine learning team
she's been with us for two and a half
years but she came from cuba we had no
idea who this person was we had no idea
that cuba had a strong systems biology
and bioinformatics division
because we just weren't spending time
scouring the cuban market for talent
but this individual found a way
to somebody important within the cyclica
environment
built a relationship with this
individual and that individual opinion
said i think you need to take this
person seriously have a conversation
and within a few weeks we hired we went
through what in canada is called the
labor market investment analysis we
invested a lot of time and capital out
of our pocket to bring this person over
to cuba and manage their entire visa
application whereby
we could have saved a lot of time and a
lot of effort to just go in our own
backyard because that individual was the
right person for us but how did they go
about it what they did not do was ping
me on linkedin
and say hey i'm interested in joining
cyclica can i have an interview because
i'm the last person that is going to
know what to do for a specific
contributor on a team so my
encouragement is linkedin is an
important tool and since sitting here 20
people have asked me to invite over
linkedin awesome i've accepted all of
you
but if you're interested in joining
cyclica understand what we're doing
understand who within the company is the
most important person to build a
relationship with build a relationship
with them it will take time and that's
the way you differentiate yourself
beyond just applying to a job on
online and so it takes effort it takes
smart it takes strategy and it takes the
will to allow the time to
come at you so if i'm going to conclude
my feedback to all of you is use the
resources that are available to you
as
a overall strategy build that strategy
and be smart about how you go about it
because it is possible and i can give
you dozens of examples of how we got
about it but each one of those that
individual
came to us in a very unique way
you very much anthony do you have any
closing remarks
i think um
you know understand your why as an
individual why
are you doing what you're doing you know
what is your what is your motivation
what is your end goal
uh
end goal in terms of what fulfills you
rather than you know a narrow short-term
research objective
uh and then try and match
your why with the why of the
organization do you want to work with
um because
if you do that then you will you know
liberate your talents and you'll deliver
something to the enterprise you're
working with
i think uh you know
just echoing what naheed says uh
the covert pandemic has caused us at
eagle genomics to build a highly
distributed global business uh because
there was just no other way and uh
actually we've discovered that that's a
competitive advantage we're not going to
go back to the old we're not going to
consolidate back to the small
narrow
geographic focus we had previously so
there never has been a better time um
but do your homework i think the
panelists have said that before
understand your why and match it with
the why of the enterprise you're seeking
to work with and then i think
you know alchemy can be liberated with
that
okay thank you uh shamir would you like
to add
something sure thank you uh so i
strongly believe uh you know
irrespective of all the advances that we
have right now whether it's in you know
within data machine intelligence
algorithms robotics we are still you
know
not close to that sort of a sort of a
dream of getting that right drug to
right patient
that would lead to you know an optimal
outcome and you know
at least side effect you know we are not
not yet there we are on a path towards
that
and we are all in this journey together
there are plenty of career opportunity
and the field is just you know getting
excited more exciting because we are now
moved from mono-ohmic dataset to
multi-omics and there is more to come
in if you look at the biological aspects
behind this so it's a really exciting
field and and we need all hands on the
deck and that's that's what i want to
kind of put together as my my my last
comment
thank you and uh tyrone maybe you could
uh
somewhere i think uh
most of my
most of my panelists have already
covered the major points i'll just keep
it on the philosophical side where i
would say
keep that inquisitiveness quotient on i
mean often what makes the difference in
the longer run is asking that one
question from someone who can help you
and more often that
i mean i have realized in my career is
that people are willing to help people
are willing to answer those questions
even if they look stupid to you
so uh you know keep on learning um there
is no limit to that
uh beef up on that knowledge
and reach out to people where where you
face hurdles and you you never know who
can be your guardian angel and can help
you
so that is something that even naheed
said you know someone reached out to him
he took that call and and often you know
you'll you'll find uh walls as well but
uh you'll also find your guardian angels
so so just keep on doing that i'm happy
to you know answer more questions on
linkedin as well i'll post my linkedin
id i connect with people uh wherever
needed so happy to help where i can
all right great thank you very much
everyone and thank you mohit for uh
moderating the panel uh would you like
to kind of summarize what we've heard so
we can transition away
yeah thank you so much i'm i mean we
have had a wonderful session with all of
you here thank you for your time and i
think we gotta learn a lot from uh
student prospective from a researcher's
perspective from in general that what
are the steps that are required for us
to take the next and we also learned
about the internship opportunities that
each of the companies have to offer
along with other opportunities and
skills that you are looking forward to
so